[Music]
hello, res gonzález greets you and this is
about information for today, Thursday, December 3,
the plan for the
distribution of vaccines was revealed in the list of
nevada and governor steve himself
detailed that the first doses of the
vaccines will arrive in the valley  in the
next two weeks he added that
healthcare workers and the
most vulnerable people will receive the
vaccine first the vaccines that will arrive
in las vegas' are manufactured by facer and
modern which show at least
95 percent effectiveness
the department of labor  The country
public its latest
unemployment figures for the state and indicate that
this week 712 thousand people applied
for unemployment benefits while
here in the state of Nevada or 7,400 more
people who applied for this aid
both figures are less than what
had been forecast  and also less
than last week
this week
the president's lawyers were allowed as well as
the lawyers of the  the president-elect me
bayrén to inspect the
voting machines and both lawyers to present
their arguments before a judge in carson
would be today the campaign of the
president of trump remains firm in
challenging the results of the election of
this past november 3  bailén won
the nevada contest generating more than 33
thousand votes for his part the secretary of
state who belongs to the
republican party has affirmed that there is no
evidence of widespread electoral fraud
in our state
one of the most anticipated
sporting events was canceled on wednesday it
is about  las vegas' bou a
college football game that was
canceled due to
pandemic safety restrictions the event takes
place every december and was expected to
generate at least 25 million dollars
to the city's economy
and today in the forecast  weather
we will have a maximum of 58 degrees with
sunny skies and a minimum of 36 for
the weekend raise the  It's temperatures
and we hope for breezes on Monday. I
wish you an excellent day,
andrés gonzález informed you, and this was about the
iu news now news in Spanish
[Music]